Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with the truth about the
involvement of Saudi Arabia in the
Islamic Republic of Iran in the
September 11th 2001 Jihad terror attack
upon the United States the 28-page
section of the 9911 report detailing
Saudi involvement in 9911 has finally
been released albeit with substantial
portion still redacted and it is now
clear why one president who held hands
with the Saudi king and another who
bowed to him worked so hard all these
years to keep these Pages secret they
confirm that the 9/11 Jihad murderers
received significant help from people at
the highest levels of the Saudi
government the report states that Omar
albumi who may be a Saudi intelligence
officer gave substantial assistance to
hijackers khed al-minar and naah Al
hamzi after they arrived in San Diego in
February 2000 albumi met the hijackers
at a public place shortly after his
meeting with an individual at the Saudi
consulate around the same time albumi
had extensive contact with Saudi
government establishments in the US and
received financial support from a Saudi
company affiliated with the Saudi
Ministry of defense that company
reportedly had ties to Usama Bin Laden
and Al-Qaeda another possible Saudi
agent Usama basan who has many ties to
the Saudi government and was also a
supporter of of Osama bin Laden boasted
that he did more for al- Minar and al-
hamzi than albumi did he also reportedly
received funding and possibly a fake
passport from Saudi government officials
the report says that at one point a
member of the Saudi royal family
provided basan with a significant amount
of cash and that he and his wife have
received financial support from the
Saudi ambassador to the US and his wife
that Ambassador was Prince bondar about
Whom The New York Times later noted no
foreign Diplomat has been closer or had
more access to President Bush his family
and his administration than the magnetic
and fabulously wealthy Prince bondar bin
Sultan of Saudi Arabia then there was
shik alumi an accredited Diplomat at the
Saudi Consulate in Los Angeles and one
of the imams at the King Fahad musque in
Culver City California who may also have
been in contact with al- Minar and Al
hamzi Salah alusan reportedly a Saudi
interior Ministry official stated at the
same hotel in hearnden Virginia where Al
hamzi was staying while alusan claimed
after 9/11 not to know the hijackers FBI
agents believed that he was being
deceptive he was able to depart the
United States despite FBI efforts to
locate and reinw him now who got him out
of the country and there's much more the
report redacts the name of another Saudi
national with close ties to the Saudi
royal family but notes that he is the
subject of FBI counterterrorism
investigations and reportedly was
checking security at the United States
Southwest border in 1999 And discussing
the possibility of infiltrating
individuals into the United
States now there's no telling who this
could have been but Prince bandar's
unlisted phone number turned up in a
phone book of Abu zubida a senior
Al-Qaeda operative captured in Pakistan
in March 2002 Abu zubida also had the
number of a bodyguard at the Saudi
Embassy in Washington the the report
also mentions a CIA memorandum that
discusses alleged Financial connections
between the September 11th hijackers
Saudi government officials and members
of the Saudi royal family this
memorandum was passed on to an FBI
investigator yet despite the clear
National implications of the CIA
memorandum the FBI agent included the
memorandum in an individual case File
and did not forward it to FBI
headquarters why not and there's much
more more with this much smoke There is
almost certainly fire however Saudi
involvement in 9/11 was not the only
subject of a cover up Iran's little
noted role in 9/11 has been covered up
as well as I detail in my new book The
Complete infidels guide to Iran on
December 22nd 2011 US District Judge
George B Daniels ruled in Havish at all
versus Bin Laden that Iran and his balah
were liable for damages to be paid to
relatives of of the victims of the 911
attacks in New York and Washington judge
Daniels found that both the Islamic
Republic of Iran and its Lebanese proxy
hisbah had actively aided al-Qaeda in
planning and executing the 911 attacks
he found that Iran and his balah had
cooperated and collaborated with
Al-Qaeda before 911 and continued to do
so after the attacks before 9/11 Iran
and hisbah were implicated in efforts to
train Al-Qaeda members to blow up large
buildings this training resulted in the
bombing of the Cobar Towers in Saudi
Arabia in 1996 the bombing of the US
embassies in Kenya and Tanzania in 1998
and the attack on the USS Cole in the
year 2000 shortly after the Cole attack
the 9/11 Jihad plot began to come
together and Iran was
involved Abu Hassam mesbahi a Defector
from Iran testified that during the
summer of 2001 he he received messages
from Iranian government officials
regarding a plan for unconventional
warfare against the United States the
plot was entitled shaan Dar atash Satan
in
Flames now Satan in Flames was the
Iranians elaborate plot to hijack three
passenger Jets each packed full of
people and crash them into American
landmarks the World Trade Center which
jihadis took to be the center of
American Commerce and the center of the
American economy the Pentagon which of
course was the center of American's
military apparatus and the White House a
classified National Security Agency
analysis referred to in the 911
Commission report reveals that 8 to 10
of the 9/11 911 hijackers traveled to
Iran repeatedly in late 2000 and early
2001 the 911 Commission called for a US
Government investigation into Iran's
role in 911 but none was ever undertaken
and so Kenneth R Timmerman of the
foundation for democracy in Iran was in
his words engaged by the Havish
attorneys in 2004 to carry out the
investigation the 911 Commission report
called on the US government to handle
Timberman noted during the 9/11 hijacker
trips to Iran that they were accompanied
by senior his balah operatives who were
in fact agents of the Iranian regime
Iranian border agents when they traveled
to Iran did not stamp their passports so
that there having been inside the
Islamic Republic would not arouse
suspicion when they entered the United
States the CIA embarrassed by its
failure to recognize the import of these
trips tried to suppress this Revelation
however Kenneth Timberman contends that
even the available evidence is explosive
enough in his words he reveals that the
911 that the Islamic Republic of Iran
helped design the 911 plot provided
intelligent support to identify and
train the operatives who carried it out
allowed the future hijackers to evade us
and Pakistani surveillance on key trips
to Afghanistan during which they
received the final order of mission from
Osama Bin Laden by escorting them
through Iranian borders without passport
stamps evacuated hundreds of top
Al-Qaeda operatives from Afghanistan to
Iran after 911 just as US forces
launched their offensive provided Safe
Haven and continued financial support to
Al-Qaeda cadres for years after 911
allowed Al-Qaeda to Iran as an
operational base for additional Terror
attacks in particular the May 2003
bombings in Riyad Saudi Arabia now the
Ayatollah K the supreme leader of Iran
he knew about the 911 plot during the
summer of 2001 he instructed Iranian
agents to be careful to conceal their
tracks he told them to communicate only
with al-qaeda's second in command Iman
Al zahiri and Imad Mia of his Bala mugia
was Iran's key player in the 9/11 Satan
inflamed plot during the Havish trial
former CIA agents CLA Lopez and Bruce
teft submitted an affidavit stating Imad
mug the most notable and notorious World
terrorist of his time an agent of Iran
and a senior operative of his Bala
facilitated the international travel of
certain 911 hijackers to and from Iran
Lebanon Saudi Arabia and Afghanistan and
perhaps various other locations for the
purpose of executing the events of
September 11th 2001 this support enabled
two vital aspects of the September 11th
2001 plot to succeed one the continued
training of the hijackers in Afghanistan
and Iran after securing their United
States visas in Saudi Arabia and two
entry into the United
States the Obama era CIA went into great
pains to try to ensure that information
about Iran's role in 911 did not come
out in the Havish case in August 2010 a
CIA official pressured a hav Havish
witness to withdraw his testimony in
exchange for a new identity new passport
and new job in December of that year
another CIA operative approached a
different Havish witness showed him
documents stolen from the case and took
him to a US Embassy where he was
subjected to 5 hours of interrogation he
was finally offered cash if he recanted
his testimony Timberman says after I
reported these attempts at witness
tampering to a congressional over it
committee they
ceased judge Daniels ultimately
determined that Iran his balah Iran's
Islamic revolutionary guard Corps the
Iranian Ministry of intelligence and
security and other Iranian government
departments as well as the ayatolla Comm
himself and former Iranian president Ali
Akbar Hashmi rafsanjani were all
directly implicated in Iranian efforts
to Aid al-Qaeda in its 911 plot Daniels
awarded the plaintiffs and the Havish
case almost $400 million in economic
damages $94 million for pain and
suffering
$874 million for mental anguish and
grief four over4 billion in punitive
damages and $968 million in prejudgment
interest for a total of over $7
billion now of course the Havish
plaintiffs are not going to get a check
from for that amount from the Islamic
Republic of Iran neatly signed by the I
to Comm still the Judgment provided a
small bit of Solace for the loss of life
and years of trauma these families have
suffered as a result of the Islamic
Republic of Iran's war against the
United States and most importantly the
Judgment stands as an acknowledgement of
Iran's role in 911 after 911 the US
declared war on terror and entered
Afghanistan and Iraq but if Bush had
been really serious about attacking
Jihad Terror at its route he would have
invaded Saudi Arabia and Iran instead
under Obama the denial and willful
ignorance have only gotten exponentially
worse I'm Robert Spencer